bienvenue chez les projets perrin une
famille homoparentale
il y à emmanuel et marion et leurs trois
enfants augustin né en 2005 et des
jumeaux nils et baptiste arrivé au monde
en 2007
les deux femmes ont eu recours à la
procréation médicalement assistée en
belgique s'est adressé à des cliniques
belges
on a reçu des réponses de cliniques
parmi celles qu'on avait contacté dont
l'une qui est l'hôpital universitaire
en flamand de
de belgique 20 de bruxelles qui avait
une procédure qui était relativement
simple et qui pouvait surtout nous
prendre rapidement pm1 on s'est rendus
la bave toutes les deux pour la première
insémination de laquelle est né augustin
ensuite quand on a décidé d'avoir un
deuxième enfant on s'est naturellement
adressé la même technique
on a eu de nouveau un rendez vous et on
a eu donc il sait baptiste qui sont
jumeaux on a vraiment un parcours assez
atypique plupart des couples retourne
une fois deux fois trois fois voire 6 7
8 fois font des essais à répétition nous
on a eu beaucoup de chance ça s'est très
bien passé ça a été très rapide pour
nils et baptiste tout se passe bien à
l'école même si leurs camarades posent
parfois des questions
bah c'est un exil de maman et me
demander des millions de fois comment
est ce que j'ai fait pour m normalement
fait je vois juste parce que ce choix je
dois me poser la question alors comment
est-ce que j'ai été c'est en et
qu'est-ce que tu vraiment bien que c'est
par insémination artificielle leur
répondais lèvera dans le dictionnaire
selon emmanuel et marion l'ouverture à
la pma est une avancée même s'il reste
des progrès à faire sur les droits pour
les familles homosexuelles
un couple hétérosexuel qui a recours à
une pma fait une reconnaissance
anticipée en mairie tout simplement
un couple homosexuel devra passer par un
notaire donc devra payer à nos terres on
a l'impression que c'est pour ménager
ménager certaines susceptibilités de
familles qui sont hostiles à notre
schéma familial et au fait qu'on ait
recours à la pma et donc on leur donne
un petit un petit quelque chose non non
ne vous inquiétez pas ils seront pas
traités tout à fait de la même manière
pas moi ça me donne cette impression
l'article sur l'ouverture à la pma pour
toutes les femmes a été voté en première
lecture le vendredi 27 septembre
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
bioéthique se poursuit au parlement